[Music]
Hey everyone, I'm Arouch. I'm a product
manager here at Google. Hey, I'm Ukun.
I'm a software engineer at Google
working on deep research. Um, so uh I
don't know if people have had a chance
to uh try deep research on Gemini um or
are familiar with the product, but you
can try it if you go to Gemini advanced
and if you scroll past 2.0 flash 2.0
flash thinking experimental 2.0 0 Flash
thinking experimental with apps 2.0 pro
experimental you will find uh 1.5 pro
with deep research which is what we
built. Um and if you have the chance to
use it and you pay the 20 bucks uh you
will see that it's a personal research
agent that can browse the web for you to
to build the reports on your
behalf. And so our motivation and what
we want to talk about today is kind of
why we built it, some of the product
challenges we overcame and some of the
technical challenges you'll face of
building a web research agent. Um so our
motivation was really we wanted to help
people get smart fast. Um we saw that
research and learning queries are some
of the top use cases in Gemini. But when
you bring like really hard questions uh
to chat bots in general, what we were
finding is that it would often give you
a blueprint for an answer rather than
actually give you the answer itself.
Right? So, we had this query that we
used to throw around of like tell me
what does it take to get an athletic
scholarship for shot put and like how do
I go get one? And often the answers
would be things like you should talk to
coaches, you should find out how far you
should be able to throw and you know uh
you should make sure you have good
grades but really what I want to know is
like okay what are the grade boundaries
like how far do I need to actually be
able to throw? I want something super
comprehensive and and that's where we
saw a big opportunity. Yeah. So we said,
what if you remove the constraints of
compute and latency at inference time,
let Gemini take as long as it wants,
browse the web as much as it needs, and
see if we can trade that off for a much
comprehensive answer for the user. But
you got to do it in 5 minutes cuz beyond
that, uh, we don't have the chips. Um,
so,
uh, this brought a bunch of product
challenges for us. Um, Gemini up to this
point is an inherently synchronous
feature. It's a chatbot. Um and so you
wanted to we needed to figure out how do
you sort of build asynchronous
experiences in in an inherently
synchronous product. Um you also wanted
to set expectations with users, right?
Deep research is good for like one very
specific thing but a lot of user queries
to Gemini are things like what's the
weather, write me a joke, things like
that where waiting 5 minutes is not
going to get you a good answer and we
wanted to set expectations. Uh, and the
last thing is our answers can be
thousands of words long and we needed to
figure out how do you make it easy for
users to engage with really long outputs
and um in in a chat
experience. Um, so let's walk through
kind of the UX and kind of think about
how how we solve some of these, right?
So imagine you're a VC uh and
everybody's talking about, you know,
investing in nuclear in America. And so
you come with this query like hey help
me learn the latest technology
breakthroughs in small nuclear reactors
and tell me interesting companies in the
supply chain. So the first step when you
bring this query to deep research is
that Gemini will actually put together a
research plan for you and present it in
a card. And so this is the first way in
which we're able to communicate with
users like this is different. This isn't
your standard chatbot experience.
Something's going to happen. You're
going to hit start. But it's also an
opportunity for us to actually show the
user a research plan that they can edit
and engage with. kind of like a good
analyst, right? They they wouldn't just
get to work. They'd actually show you,
okay, here's how I'm going to approach
this. And it's a way for users to if
they want kind of engage and steer the
direction of the research
further. Now,
uh once it you hit start, we actually
try and show you um what Gemini is doing
under the under the hood in real time uh
by showing you the the websites it's
browsing. And this is a feature that was
built before thinking models and
thoughts are also a really great way of
kind of showing transparency of what the
model is thinking. Um but what's really
nice here is while you wait you can sort
of click through the websites dive into
any of the content. Um but what we also
inadvertently saw is people trying to
game that number to see how high it
could go. So we definitely saw people
push that number into the into the
thousands uh to try and um you know see
how many websites deep research could
read.
Um, finally we kind of get this report
that's, you know, thousands of words
long. And, um, we're really inspired by
what kind of what Anthropic does with
artifacts. And so, we thought that was a
really great way of sort of being able
to pin an artifact so that users can
actually ask questions about the
research while reading the material.
They don't have to scroll back and
forth. And what's really neat about this
is it means it's easy for you to engage
in sort of changing the style of the
report, adding sections, removing
sections, asking follow-up questions and
uh and it sort of makes that really
easy. And the last part that's super
important is kind of user trust and also
doing right by the publishers. So we we
try and always show as all the sources
we read as well as all the sources we
used in the report because not
everything that we read is used but it
stays in context for follow-up questions
and and also sort of these are all
things that um carry over to Google Docs
as citations and things like that if you
choose to export.
uh so I thought today we can pick some
of the challenges uh that one has to
encounter while building a research
agent and talk through some of them. So
uh I picked four for today. So one is
this this longunning nature of tasks
introduce a couple of things that we
need to look into. Second is the model
has to plan iteratively and spend uh its
time and compute during this time
effectively. So what are those
challenges there? And it has to do this
uh while interacting with a very noisy
environment that is the web. And as you
do this and uh read through information
very quickly you can start seeing your
context grow and how do you effectively
manage
context? So if if you think about a job
that runs for multiple minutes and
something that can make many many uh
different LLM calls and calls to
different services, there are bound to
be failures, right? And today we're
talking about o of minutes, but you can
very easily think in the future of uh
these kind of research agents taking
like multiple hours. So it's important
to be robust to intermediate failures of
these various services of various
reliabilities and so being able to build
a good state management solution being
able to recover from errors effectively
so that you just don't drop the whole
research uh task due to one failure.
That's one. The second aspect of doing
this what it enables us is to enable
this feature uh crossplatform. So we
believe more and more uh users will
start kind of registering your asks uh
or your research tasks and just like
walk away do their thing and then you
need to get notified and this can happen
now across uh devices and you can pick
off uh uh reading it uh uh uh once it's
done. So now what is the model doing at
uh like through these you know uh few
minutes. Uh so let's take a example
right. So here uh we're looking for uh
athletic scholarships uh for shortput.
There are many facets to this query and
we kind of show this in a research plan
like showed. The first thing the model
has to do is try to figure out which of
these sub problems it can start tackling
in parallel versus things that are
inherently sequential. Right? So the
model has to be able to reason to do
that. And uh the other challenge is here
you see you're always going to land in
this state where there's partial
information. So it's important to look
at all the information found so far
before you decide what to do next. So in
this instance the model found hey it's
it knows the qualifying standards uh for
the D1 division but in order to provide
a complete report and answer the user's
question it has to go figure out what
the equivalent for the D2 and D3
divisions are. So this notion of being
able to ground on information you find
and then plan your next step is
key. Another example of partial
information could be when you make
searches u so in this case you're trying
to find the best roller coaster for
kids. Uh you might find results uh that
provide partial information again. So
here uh you end up at a link uh which
talks about the top 10 roller coasters
but does not mention anything about them
being suitable to kids. Uh so the
planner has to recognize this fact and
then go ahead and in the next steps of
planning try to resolve this uh
disambiguity. Um another example of uh
challenges in planning is information is
often not found in one place. you find
facets of information spread across
different sources. So here uh we're
trying to find uh what would uh what
would it take to get a certification for
a scuba dive uh in in in some dive
centers nearby. So you see uh one part
or one source has uh the kind of the
structure of uh what what you have to go
through to get a certification but in a
completely different source you have
this notion of the pricing for this
diving center. So the model has to weave
this together to figure out uh you know
what the cost structure for such a
certification would look
like. Then there's the classic uh entity
resolution problem. So you might find
mentions of the same entity across
different sources. So you need to be
able to reason about some information
indicators to kind of figure out if
they're talking about the same entity or
you need to explore more to verify such
uh disabilities.
Um yeah, I think most people here have
worked on some notion of a web problem
and we know like it's super fragmented.
So uh here you see two different
websites uh talking about the same thing
uh about music festivals in Portugal
this year. Uh on the left uh if you end
up at such a website it's easier and you
get most of your information in one go.
Uh on the right uh the layout is
different. So having a robust browsing
mechanism if you want to navigate uh the
web for your research tasks is another
uh important
challenge. So like we saw there is lot
of these intermediate outputs and as you
do this and you start getting streams of
information during your planning you can
imagine your context size growing very
quickly. Um the other challenge that uh
about context size is your research task
doesn't typically end with your first
query. People have follow-ups. People
can say hey can you also do the same for
this other topic. So there is like this
kind of a follow-up uh deep research and
uh that also adds pressure on the
context. Uh we at Gemini have uh the
liberty of really long context models.
uh but uh even then you have to design
uh some way to make sure you you
effectively manage your context and
there are multiple choices here each
come with various different trade-offs.
Uh we're showing one here uh where we
kind of have like this recency bias. So
you have lot more information about your
current and your previous tasks but as
you get to older tasks we kind of
selectively pick out uh you know things
what we call as research notes and put
it in a rag that way the model can still
access it but it's being selective. Uh
I'll hand it back to about uh to talk
about what's next. Yeah. So we were
super
excited to put this feature out in
December. We weren't actually sure if
anyone was going to use it, if anyone
was gonna care um to wait five minutes
uh for something. And uh we were really
positively surprised by the reception.
Um and and really what we what we saw um
was, hey, we've built something that's
maybe as good as like a Mackenzie
analyst, right? And we give it away for
20 bucks. But um you know, that's that's
really great. And u but what it does is
it just retrieves from the open web and
it's a text in text out only system,
right? And so where we sort of we sort
of see a few different directions of
where research agents are going to go
next. And the first one is around
expertise, right? So how do you go from
Mackenzie analyst to a Mackenzie partner
or Goldman Sachs partner or like a
partner to law firm, right? So that's
really around not just being able to
aggregate information and synthesize it,
but also think through the so what of
how do like what are the implications
for what we're going to do and what are
the most interesting insights and
patterns that come out of it. The the
other thing is you know there are plenty
of domains beyond professional services
like the sciences where you you know
want to get really good you know you
want something that can read many papers
form hypotheses find really interesting
patterns in you know what methods we
used uh and and come up with novel
hypothesis to explore. However, um just
because you build something that can be
really smart doesn't mean that it's
useful to someone, right? So, um if we
were thinking about a use case of
running a due diligence on a company,
the way you'd present that information
to me would be very different to the way
you'd present that information to say a
Goldman Sachs banker, right? Um, for me,
you really want to talk through like
what like what is this company and how's
it positioned strategically, but a
banker would want to know all the
financial information, actually have a
DCF that they could look at, right?
Actually uh have a have a much more like
fine grained uh sort of uh finan uh
financial modeling and analysis and and
that really should shape the way in
which you browse the web, right? The way
you browse the web, the way you frame
your answer, the kind of questions you
pursue should be very personalized to
kind of meeting the user where they're
at. I think the last part is sort of
something that goes across domains of
what models can do, right? So not just
being able to do web research with text,
but being able to combine that with
abilities in coding, data science, even
video generation, right? So coming back
to this example, if you're doing a due
diligence, what if it could go and do
like a lot of statistical analysis and
actually build financial models to
inform the research output that it gives
you, right? Telling you, hey, why is
this a good company or not?
Um, I should say Google doesn't give
financial advice and you know it's not a
financial adviser. Um, but yeah, and so
we're really excited about the
potential. We think there's a ton of
headroom to make research agents better
and we are really glad we didn't call
this Gemini Deep Dive, which was our
best name before uh before launching
this feature. Um, that's it. Thank you
so much. Thank you.
[Music]